hello welcome to honest trailer
commentary is coming to you not live
pre-tape but we are talking about
detective Pikachu yeah yeah LAN Dan all
with me to discuss our behind-the-scenes
thought process stick around
after we watched the trailer together to
get some cut scenes cut jokes responding
to your opinions Corrections questions
comments and tease for next week's
honest trailer mmm-hmm
but that's next week today we're talking
about the detective Pikachu yeah a film
I quite enjoyed I didn't love it but
I've loved I loved it was the best
detective Pikachu movie it looks great I
mean I'm just gonna cards they're like I
love the way that rhyme city looks I
like the wind and the Pikachu or the
Pokemon were real I love the score this
was really good like it just they
actually do a good job of like that film
noir detective kind of look and
aesthetic and bringing that into the
movie yes Holly Pressman I loved the way
all of the furry anything that any
Pokemon that was supposed to be just
skin was very disturbing to me if it if
it was fluffy I wanted to hug it and put
it in my pocket but like lick a ton is
the grossest thing I've never seen in my
time where does that I guess it's always
hanging out that seems like a cruel
twist of nature never bring your tongue
back in your mouth where you saying that
this represents the totality like
suppose you - Pokemon okay movie yeah
and I have to say I was most interested
in it when it was showing me things
about Pokemon that I wanted to learn
more about and I was least interested in
it when it became a mystery interesting
and I really care for the cuz I found
the mystery to be like it's very easy to
figure out on many sides which we'll
talk about but yeah I felt like it was a
really unique a world and a concept that
I wanted to learn more back about
married to a very conventional
predictable easy to deduce the story
that I'm like I would have preferred
more of the weird crazy stuff that I
didn't know about yet less of the
standard
but I think you need a detective or
journalist which there also isn't that's
like the standard fall back on plot
device for someone to take you through a
world to have like a plot reason to ask
questions and be like oh what's this
what's that oh good I like that I you
know with like when he went to the see
the lieutenant and he's in a the the
police you know Ken Watanabe and he's
got his own Pokemon and then but he then
they leave so I was like like do like a
cop drama I know it's a little bit more
like Zootopia like maybe we go with cops
and also their Pokemon and you learn
more about like I liked this crazy city
and how did it work and what was the
what was the have what was the whole
vibe of it it's like background noise
for a lot of the movie and I was like I
want to learn more but maybe it's
because I don't know a lot about Pokemon
so did you want like a Pokemon
ride-along where it's like you get to be
mean even though this is based on an
actual Pokemon game that was like a
pretty straightforward buddy detective
story it feels like it was a studio note
work I was like no one's gonna watch
just Pokemon they don't need it may make
them a detective or something like that
go to the feel like straight-up action
kinda doesn't work either like as we
kind of referenced this in the trailer
that it's a little bit of a power
differential I mean some of these
Pokemon are so powerful and then you're
just humans running away so I think you
have to do something so you're not just
leaning into big action set pieces right
so they have to be like investigating
something or figuring something out so
that you're not just like running away
from Pokemon for 90 minutes if you can
hear they're currently drilling through
the walls
[Music]
try not to laugh that's fine you know it
stop okay detective you go follow their
also painting everything around us and
I'm super high us boxing like hazmat
suits so Pokemon and Ryan Reynolds you
definitely hate video game movies and
you probably don't have a hot take on
film noir now you don't rush it all
together and hope something clicks is
Pokemon detective Pikachu love the
aesthetic you havin or think I do think
it clicked but I hope that now that
they've given you your first little
Pokemon fix that they can just kind of
abandon the pretense of other genres and
just make a book throw me in the water
if you're right yeah neck deep you gotta
be in there with the squirtles and I'm
ready to star meas you know all them
water types eleven I mean wouldn't a
conventional Pokemon movie just be like
it would have to be like a sports yeah
be Rocky right yeah or like kung-fu like
he's wandering from town to town killing
not killing beating up some kind of
Karate Kid style you know there's a
middle ground where it doesn't have to
be a Pokemon versus Pokemon movie where
you're in rhyme City but you can also do
yeah I mean cuz in the games along the
way like you're taking down the mob yeah
you in one of the games I believe you
you've captured God who is a Pokemon so
God need with the starship what does a
child need with God in a pokeball in
Pokemon I'm not sure that would work
yeah anyways let's keep going it was the
fifth Star Trek you get ready polka fans
after 21 animated movies 22 seasons of
TV and countless video games Pokemon is
finally getting a live action film based
on the weird spin-off that no one bought
outside Japan I'm sorry but can we
investigate your cloaks probably the
right choice to adapt since every other
polka thing is a dogfighting simulator
pay2win card game or a playable corpse
finder we all had Pokemon go what see
all of your favorite Pokemon come to
life on the big screen like Charizard
the tongue was nope nope yeah it's a
weird choice cuz there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of Pokemon to
choose from and I feel a lean toward the
horrific the game has to offer a Pokemon
who can take the form of anyone so that
you can use them as like an undercover
operative I get it it makes sense if
you're doing a mystery cloak-and-dagger
sort of it's just the way that it's
visualized is really terrifying with the
coralline dot eyes and just don't like
it you know I think would be a great
ditto in the next Pokemon movie Jennifer
Lawrence for one scene yeah ya know
there was I'm very vocal when I watched
these movies in the office I try not to
be but it can't help it and the scene
where the speaker book I can remember
the name the speaker Pokemon are like oh
yeah in your face I just go no no
because I made all that I thought it was
a cool idea although it did all of this
raises so many questions to me about
pokémon like sentience and agency
because like there are they voluntarily
employed as a speaker system or they
they have like Flintstone yeah I think
that's the point of rhyme city is that
like because you know some of them are
cops like that one guy who is like
directing traffic yeah yeah in rhyme
city they have jobs which to me is like
okay so there is there is a way that
Pokemon can have more agency yeah
everywhere else they just come out and
fight and then go it's like the
n-c-double-a like every other part of
the world I originally thought it was
like a Flintstones thing but none of
them ever turned to the camera go they
can only save their name it's sort of
like the goofy Pluto problem where it's
like the existence of that's not rhyme
City are these P into eugenics territory
of like which Pokemon are smart enough
you know to be always breathing them
there's always sort of odd animal
husbandry aspects to it just seems like
it's darker the deeper you I just want
to picture Bill Nighy in a room having
to be taught about all this he can get
into character what kind of eugenics are
we doing from these Pokemon but for
those who don't know or care grab ahold
of Ryan Reynolds Pikachu I will
electrocute you a detective who's
wisecracking charm could carry a premise
as dumb as well detective Pikachu
because no matter how you feel about
Pokemon this is the closest we'll get to
a new Deadpool for a while and I mean
come on just look
little guy yeah movies alright I mean
he's a Pikachu's a detective you get
what you pay for so Fossum there was a
the big fan petition or effort was to
get Danny DeVito to play Pikachu who
when asked about it at a junk it was
like I don't know what the hell I
assumed that started because like the
guy who did the voice in the game
sounded like him but we just heard it
and no he doesn't
yeah I remember it being like you know
filtered through 13 layers of BS movie
news websites and it was like Danny
DeVito detective question yeah okay yeah
I know every time I ever interviewed
Danny DeVito I'm going to have to ask
him about today yeah so we'll see
because because that's cuz clicks baby
get those clicks just telling you want
to see them aliens now that they've
separated the two I guess we'll get to
that later we'll get to it you go one to
act scared so animated lizard they call
justice Smith character who sounds
exactly like his dad I had this question
afterwards as I attempted to unpack this
so much time back
did he not recognize his own father it's
a big problem with leave early enough
for him to not know the sound of his
voice no he was at the train station is
kind of a boy yeah it was like 8 right
is a very recognizable familiar voice
yeah I feel like I would know the voice
of either of my parents even if it were
coming out of a small fuzzy creature yes
yeah I'd be more jarring right I'd be
like mom even if grant him the fact that
like we're just hearing Tim's we're
inside Tim's brain somehow like it's not
like
because everyone else is we know
everyone else is hearing pika-pika right
so this is all from inside his head he'd
be like you sound just like my dead
father oh my god there wouldn't even
just be the sound of the voice
presumably that's also his dad's
personality yes so would be like exactly
like my dad yes you were with my father
when he disappeared by memory you have
all the same tics as my dad you both
love getting coffee dad does yeah
where's the caffeine really like I get
that Pikachu's the detective but come on
I have to go back in and check that all
right keep going good point dopinder
could have cracked this in like five
seconds but with the help of this girl
from a completely different movie but I
don't fear fear I walk the walk and I
talk the talk and I'm willing to do
whatever it takes to get the honest
scoop and that's the hard truth they'll
uncover almost just been seen it's yeah
anyways she's just doing like 1950s
snappy noir pattern she watched Jennifer
Jason Leigh and hudsucker practices it's
just that one seed yeah and all right
well yeah that's cool I liked her just
didn't know what movie that was be keep
going yes a little uncover a businessman
secret oh sorry Burt Islands and that
reminds me we didn't put it in the in
the the trailer but speaking of film
noir he is watching at one point right
the movie from home alone yeah but not
as if it's home alone like as if the
movie itself exists in this yes that
kind yes again this universe yeah it is
canonically in the same universe as home
alone let's just say hey yeah brain
because in our real
angels with dirty faces does not exist
right right so yes this is so in the
world of home alone there are pokemons
mimic a liver unless we're talking
multiverse yeah and there is you know
Kevin McCallister is a gengar just to
throw one out there and so there is like
but then for that booth same movie to
exist I don't know mm-hmm very specific
very strange we're in the ruins of our
current date where a few imaginary film
survives so yeah it's the only
explanation that fits this universe and
our serenity now right that whatever
weird person wrote faces and then also
Seinfeld exists because he does so Randy
now serenity now right the Holocaust
happened dresses global warming which is
like yeah Pokemon can't help out with
that always yeah I just type at this
point right son I mean the only fracture
point is home alone seemed to be that
that movie existed so we have to assume
that this is a universe that is also
exactly like our own save for the
existence of that film yeah I mean on a
number of universes there's that one
demon exists and also the fake noir
movie from home yeah if they're watching
ding ding dong in Pokemon too
thank you gun it's man secret plot to
merge humans and pokémon because movie I
mean I get why he would want a polka
body but why would he bother to make all
of humanity
oh you don't have to be can use it oh do
you yeah pause I mean it just seems like
a step too far
even if his presumed goal is like oh
it's the perfect mix it's the next step
in evolution like he's making most
people worse off by merging with their
Pokemon who were like a variety of you
know once let's just say a little lower
on the it's a lot more complicated and
hard to pull off and it doesn't benefit
him in any way it hurts him right if he
just as a person was like hey I'm sick
billionaire and I engineered this
Pokemon to put my brain into it people
would be kind of like okay because he
had to then go out and everybody else
now go inside their pet duck his plan is
bad because the moment that anyone
succeeds in pulling that headgear off of
his human body it's okay it's over like
so you'd have to keep your body and like
ice he was gonna have you to put him
into a but he's kind of like probably
did that first human brain and to keep
your corporeal the purpose is he died
he's dying exactly see he's got it he's
gotta figure out how to do this
permanently to seem like he permanently
merged everybody else right which is the
whole point yeah and you also do the
beds
the gas I feel like was a red herring
like you didn't really need the gas to
do that either cuz he merges we needs
the gases like the essential first step
before you can enter a poky
but did he but he did Pikachu didn't
need that and and ran ran didn't Mewtwo
before he entered a YouTube body but
you're right juice you two seems able to
do he looks like Ryan Reynolds sounds
yeah I stopped caring franchise known
for fighters read get only the tiniest
glimpse of its potential then thrill at
action set-pieces
where our heroes run away from a pokemon
run away from a pokemon run away from a
pokemon run away from this forest that's
actually a Pokemon and run away from hey
not for the games say it just say it
Pokemon so get ready for a film that was
a bit too dark for kids are you gonna
make me into a lampshade and a bit too
cutesy for adults but nonetheless takes
its rightful place as the third best
hard core times pause ice a lot of
people I see are responding where's the
Great Mouse Detective then I forgot
sorry it does belong in there long as
much to wait no we originally had Great
Mouse Detective at number five below
cool world and Michael Knight and my
point was the Great Mouse Detective
should be well where do you put that
above or below P LJ I'm saying this is
what we had we had number one number
number one Roger Rabbit to Zootopia
three cool world four Great Mouse
Detective that was yet that was not in
the script right that was just the
graphic and then we had detective
Pikachu slide in here between Zootopia
cool then my comment was you would never
have had cool world ranked above Great
Mouse Detective to begin with now but we
want to keep the
line suck it cool world we did so what's
we just removed great mass yeah that's
the easiest fix would we keep great
mouse detective is that above or below
Pikachu do we think at this table I
would keep it above Pikachu myself I
would have it at number three still it's
been a while also Vincent Price is the
voice of the villain and that well it's
a great vocal performance okay well you
be the judge audience
just imagine Great Mouse Detective
somewhere in that list let us know in
the comments you drank Great Mouse
Detective on this list okay anyways keep
going featuring cartoon animals ever
suck it cool world story just as for
Smith little yellow different new print
April Owens at Newport hours jog we
start running after one of the old rhyme
city honestly this cats trailer doesn't
look so bad and when you need a British
stage actor to class up disposable pop
culture you call Bill Nighy how are they
gonna get Ryan Reynolds back inside the
Pikachu
Oh or is it gonna be the other way
around yeah there was originally a more
enthusiastic pika pika Kevin changed it
and into a more sensual one it's funnier
but it's too real what can you say about
that yeah except for a sequel is already
yeah it's a very legitimate question
because they've separated the two which
is a little sad cuz like well now who is
Pikachu is he just like a shell that
doesn't know this now does he have
amnesia and not know what happened over
the last adventure that they said he was
in the Sun can play yes
see see what yeah sorry jerk a lot of
crazy implications so yeah Ryan Reynolds
as Pikachu how is he gonna get stuck
back in that that was a crazy villain
plot is he gonna voluntarily enter the
Pikachu again maybe I think he's got
he's gonna have to right I don't have to
be something were for this mission he's
got to go undercover as his Pikachu or
something yeah yeah maybe they'll lean
into that whole like well you know the
kid wanted to be a trainer and so now
they have to go like you know maybe
they'll do more exploring if these like
underground Pokemon fights and they can
be like a team yeah right okay I'm a
writer Pokemon training there you go
let's get to some people's opinions so I
think we should address the why right
balance is not in this trailer because
that's all oh we have deleted scenes
yeah okay stick around - I will explain
you have to be deleted scenes thank you
story actually catch you up he's not at
work
Tim short circuit first shock Holmes big
league chew bird box netdom buddy
king of the monster cops super nintendo
and you put him in this movie and he
doesn't say let them fight come on on
utopia paw Patrol pika pika bang bang
kiss kiss chu Chu's look who's talking
non-lethal weapon
okay you just pass out you don't get
killed
yeah thankful so at the end of the
Deadpool to honest trailer we had John
say we said he'll be back for a
detective Pikachu Dan I have a cannon
explanation and a non cannon explanation
for why this happened
cannon wise we know Deadpool we don't
know reference back to you know that was
a promise we made but Deadpool said
nothing yeah now now I'm canonically not
only did I we not have an idea for a
cameo but we also did not ask him to so
it's not like he stood us up or said no
we just didn't reach out yeah so it's
weird it's that damned if you do damned
if you don't thing which is that when we
did the Deadpool 2 trailer we got Ryan
Reynolds that's it's not easy to do that
he's very nice too early it's very easy
but I mean it's like yeah sure as far as
writing and stuff and like coordinating
and getting the files but you know it's
not an easy process it's been a lot more
time writing ously we only have a one
shot at recording with them and B we
want to make sure that it's like super
good stuff big movie star yesterday we
did Deadpool 2 and like a very sizable
chunk of the audience was just like you
know like wow you didn't do a trailer
for Deadpool 2 because they're very non
plus by the fact that we have rights
they were very upset that we did not do
an honest trailer for the movie so now
this time we didn't get Ryan Reynolds
and we did do the honors trailer for the
movie and now we'll be probably like
where's Ryan Reynolds so it's like we
just did not betray us he's not up and
investor ghosts as we didn't ask him and
I didn't want to be like hey Ryan do you
have any ideas do pit bulls and things
around like we want to go like we have
the perfect way to work you into this we
wanted to save it for the hit man's
bodyguard to wife's bodyguard that would
be good coming out so I don't know what
to say so he's our on it
he'll be in every honest really close
this new Alan yeah sorry about that
so let's get to your other comments and
questions Charles Brown this movie did
everything right and still no one saw it
this is why we can't have nice things
Dan did people like 400-500 say no one
saw I do we have a charge for this it
was equal it did okay but it was not the
runaway hit that many thought that it
had the potential to be it was a little
softer than perhaps was expected I think
a lot of people were like oh this is
gonna spawn a massive franchise and I
think that people were the pod the
response was positive but not
overwhelming yeah yeah I do think it
seems like it's a movie that was pretty
well received as pride poised to find a
bigger audience on VOD yeah yeah I mean
it has the ignoble honor of being the
best video game movie I think that's
pretty non-controversial I mean it's
like this or technically Angry Birds 2
versus scorpion sure that segment
fantastic theme song from anybody move
all right I can see best movie
soundtrack to play late to is now the
best reviewed video game movie angry
birds 2 Angry Birds 2 movie really the
best really they like they really no I
just was the best when I okay drew
Kaplan writes everything with the
Pokemon was great and the world-building
was great everything with the human
characters was bad still really fun
movie you know I I didn't dislike
justice Smith and girlfriend Lucy yeah
I don't know I could watch justice and
Ryan Reynolds and Pikachu go on the next
one but you're right I don't think they
were bad but I don't think they were
given too much to do it was a more
torture cell yeah like towards the end
that kind of but I cried everything as
everyone at this table knows so that got
me a little bit when it's like they had
their like cat's in the cradle moment
it's like I'll come live with you we see
somebody a train ticket valid train Tia
and the garbage that is that is just a
blatant disregard for money and it sent
it to a Pokemon and let them come to
rhyme City and be free nothing like he's
in this movie for I don't know you could
have pretty much any act to do that
obviously he's great he has a lot of
gravitas well why is that character even
necessary I don't know I hope he's in
more though yeah and kind of a nothing
role yeah I agree with Drew on that one
well there you go
that's O'Brien Turk writes question
frost commentary have you considered
bringing back the hook clip you used in
the previous Pokemon trailer oh yeah
yeah that's because that was from that
movie in particular of every character
going so no you haven't until now so
thank you Brian maybe it'll sneak its
way in can we correct the correction
there yeah sure okay I thought this was
so stupid I wasn't gonna bring it up but
here we go somebody I'm not gonna call
them out right you forgot the question
mark in the ending title who framed
Brian Reynolds we did not okay
Who Framed Roger Rabbit does not have a
question yeah well there you go your
correction is incorrect that's Who
Framed Roger Rabbit yeah yeah
just come online I guess it's like 50
years old yeah suck take it on them I
say keep up with Disney that's all I
want to say about detective Pikachu
yeah I hope their sequels Ryan Reynolds
we'll be back next week yeah for our
honest trailer yes holy moley
holy moley yeah this is gonna be a good
one that's all you're getting
and we hope we see then thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]